When writing code in many languages,
it's common to have features that span multiple files.
Let's say you have a function that currently takes one argument defined in
one file and a call to this function in another file.
If you want to change this function to take an additional argument,
you'll need to simultaneously change code in both files.
In many of the non-code oriented version control systems we
mentioned previously, files are tracked one at a time.
If I open two Google docs and edit both of them,
then later I want to find the versions of the files before I made either of
the edits, first I have to find the right version in one doc, then dig through
the other one's log to find the revision for approximately the same time.
That's doable, but really annoying.
Let's consider a few situations to
think about whether tracking files individually or together makes more sense.
For example, competition-style coding.
In case you're not familiar with them, most coding competitions just ask you
to solve a problem that can be done in a single file.
Another example would be an HTML file and
a CSS file that together make up a web page.
Or maybe some photos you've Photoshopped.
Or a novel, split up into multiple chapters.
For each of these situations,
if you think it makes more sense to track the files together rather than
separately, check the box next to it.